hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play cry of fear
for now as you know if you're a new
visitor
I play cry feel cry fear is an excellent
excellent mod for half-life 1 I have to
play through of it and they have
multiple custom campaigns that come out
with every update of cry of fear I'm a
big fan of team psyche size scholar and
I hope you all enjoy this because some
of the people that have been making
these custom campaigns are rival the
quality of the sort of thing it's you
know amnesia custom campaign and and one
of them actually which was a big collab
was more than excellent because it
featured a lot of really talented people
anyway here we go I actually just
recently reinstalled cry fear so I'm
very excited to get back into it
I meant to do this a while back but and
with the computer troubles I've been
happy made by Evan hallway sorry I'm
eating population I'm more professional
than that oh that was a close escape and
I have a gun now if you're like if you
haven't seen this before yes this is a
half-life 1 and earn mod not an addict
okay I have one flare guessing it's
going to get dark yeah
come on okay hang on wait I can what
we're going on here why can't those are
quick select there we go it's been a
while since I've played it but I do
remember how to play okay
my phone is completely out of batteries
in its dingdong damn dark okay
Knights lair oh it's all rad Wow get
that other flare and we'll be on our way
cuz we don't on uh-oh what the balls
that's just baloney bah so angry
it's punched the stairs okay come on all
right
couldn't make things too easy on me I
really am a big fan the reason I'm such
a fan of cry fears because it really
embraces the aspect of survival horror
like a lot of games haven't I mean yeah
it has guns but in the long run these
guns don't help a lot if you don't
ration them correctly like you know the
original Resident Evil you know like the
original games that need to be played
now that we're played oh I feel like
something evil is behind it you know
games used to be
okay I died I have a bi of a good
feeling of what sex was that oh also the
atmosphere of the game is crazy oh man
it's seriously if this game out of all
the games I've played criteria probably
has the best atmosphere besides maybe
amnesia
okay I can't get back there come on
budge same old story different scenario
doors stuck and won't open ah damn it
what the hell both alone no don't give
me the gun oh geez oh I can combo gun
flare you're kidding right I didn't know
that I would have done that in the first
game oh I needed me here coming Holly
balls okay should take that phone better
oh that was easy to miss okay combine
that here I don't need this anymore
okay drop that just go to gun combo
there we go
what how did I get to what huh wha look
like what
[Music]
some of the interface stuff is kind of
wonky but pink hang on
some reason my phone battery is it's
it's not there we go yeah some of the
interface stuff is a little wonky buddy
it's all designed to yeah really embrace
I'm eating popcorn again why am i doing
it huh it was choked up by popcorn
alright any was about to say that I
kissed enough ass already so I'll just
let the game speak for itself now
[Music]
just the music love the music can I
punch that can I punch that I can't even
Crouch jump nope can't go there dum-dum
very ominous hey whoa hey where'd you
come from
ha ha Wow haha hey buddy
Harry damn let's go one guy was a pansy
the other guy was tough I might a
headshot him ok when we gonna hear
something is holding the door shut from
the other side why am I not surprised
oh there we go
some of the doors oh oh no oh no oh no
ok all these doors are fake maybe was
this out
[Music]
hahaha oh no no no you didn't see him
[Music]
hey guy I hate that guy so much I hate
him I know what that is all of my old
saves are gone oh no oh I love cry here
hey look it's a hole it's the side that
might swing gross hey where'd you come
from
come on I only got one bullet damn it
I'm out of bullets and my phone doesn't
work the battery in it I don't know it
out balls I'll punch you in the frickin
nose jay-z dick I forgot how to dodge it
has been a while
okay so jumping down the hole probably a
bad idea but it might be the only way a
guy gotta go okay no no oh hi what
alright Oh huh
what wait wait I
okay I put batteries into this thing but
it still doesn't work so uh what I oh I
see their ledges ha is that guy still
there no I see there are little ledges
here okay I got this I got this
Oh God huh what did flat goodness gravy
alright I got this I got this I wasn't
expecting a puzzle platformer
okay so just gonna jump
- there huh yeah oh I made it huh nailed
it nailed it I see my next ledge right
if I had a flashlight it would be much
easier
nope oh those phone batteries don't work
what's up oh no wait
[Music]
and there we go
no what no that did it that did it
you bastard way maybe got a reload or we
pull out the phone ah ha ha there we go
ha ha that is much better okay I
actually figured that out now
so now huh huh good dude
oh I'm bad at these so I'm very worried
yeah dude
Oh God come on I'm making this easy on
me huh yeah yeah I'm just scared don't
worry
oh god oh god oh god oh oh
so fat ah oh that didn't hurt that bad
okay okay yes
hmm there's so good of mine what can I
use my okay how's about thing is this
something out of mine ding-dong damn it
I knew I wanted to be a miner okay I
just I don't have any bullets so I'm
just gonna stick with my fists here
fisticuffs
come on evil demons from another
dimension I can take you I'm a badass I
am a badass come on come on what you got
come on what you got I got fists of fury
I'm a level 90 monk oh it's you crazy
oh not the baby oh there's like the
freakiest monster in here Oh God God
just died just please God normal babies
I mean is this kind of disturbing on a
whole nother level which plane like
going here I'm gonna die and I'm not
gonna be able to save No what's wrong
with your face oh my god oh just get
away doesn't know stop it just between
your hammer God Bob not at me Oh God
it's probably your head oh look at it
doctor - look at that cheese
what's wrong with you
I heard that ah damn boss oh I heard
that too yep one punch hell yeah Fist of
Fury okay I got it
okay I got a gun here you reload it and
then I'll use the gun phone combo oh god
I'm badly hurt okay it's hit the button
first and then do stuff okay yep loop
super juice all right so back done yeah
of course please Amy what down there
what's down there look over here I got a
magazine to a gun that I don't have yet
so I'm assuming this nearby here I'm
gonna be pwned this is what I meant by
survival horror as in I you're your ammo
gets wasted if you if you don't use the
full clip like in real life you know and
I'm gonna waste three bullets here by
reloading early but if I get caught
without em oh I can't reload while I
have that phone out so what ended here
screw this I'm gonna hand it here cuz I
don't have enough time between now and
whenever the next save point is so I got
a judge carefully so thank you all so
much for watching I hope you're enjoying
the return to cry fear like I certainly
am so thanks again and as always I will
see
you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
[Music]